no
5le
m
[Applause]
because we still have a testimony of the
2019 fire here that we left his
keystone milk which are here to fall
during the fire have perforated this
nineteenth century heating network
and below that  there is a
stratification which is extremely dense
and interesting and exciting because
we are not we are not just
anywhere we are already on the island of the city we
are at notre dame and what is more we are in
the  the crossroads of france is
then the lead sarcophagi
viollet-le-duc we had already found
during his work in the 19th century they
were all from the modern era and
had a funerary plaque precisely which
indicated that he was the person here we did not
has no funeral plaques and we can
consume at its chronology we still remain
on a hypothesis is it
from the 14th century is it a
little bit more recent and that there was
only one one  actually opening
the sarcophagus could we will
allow ap  to carry these elements of understanding
he could not pass an
endoscopic camera inside which made it possible
to identify remains remains of
tissues remains of docile organic matter
such as hair and
remains of widows and plants, in particular
at the  level of the head with small
sheets at first reading it looks like
noise but it is to be confirmed and it is
a practice precisely which
also reserved for a social elite where we are not going to
talk about a good time but also about
maximum preservation  of the body and
here we are and suddenly the presence the
fact that these plant remains are still
there presages an excellent quality of
conservation of its contents